but the situation for men and women is
not getting any better in terms of AI in
fact it is only getting worse apps have
created virtual girlfriends that talk to
you love you allow you to live out your
erotic fantasies it's not I don't need
you to make me happy anymore now the
question is does a relationship at all
or relationship with you is it more
trouble than it's worth people can
develop mentally and Visually
relationships with AI devices or people
AI girlfriends are ruining an entire
generation of men can you have a loving
relationship with AI we've attached
ourselves to something we can see but
not interact with for a long time and
the imagination is filled in the gaps to
gratify our desires can't physically see
God and yet God wants a relationship
with you you can communicate and
essentially it's all matters of the
heart one day soon you'll be able to
interact physically with God in the
meantime the bond that has formed is
intellectual it's emotional it's
spiritual AI comes in and takes it to
the next level it offers something you
can see you do the same things that you
were doing with God but now with a
visual to match this whole AI thing
sometimes I think is getting out of
control have you heard about this girl
she's 23 and she's making probably $5
million a year because she's replicated
her interactions like chats posts
YouTube comments everything it's all
been ingested by Ai and now people can
communicate with
her they can call a number almost like a
900 number and it's like a dollar a
minute to interact with this AI That's
modeled after this girl so this is like
only fans with email kind of I
mean a little more sophisticated
technologically I think but she's
cloning herself to be I forget her name
other people yeah she's like just saw
where everything was going but how how
interesting but anyway I was I was
fascinated by this in the fact that
people are starting to gravitate
especially men are starting to gravitate
towards having an artificial
intelligence
girlfriend wait isn't it weird that like
a couple thousand people have the same
girlfriend I mean it's not your own it's
yeah you're you're probably sharing the
same server
but when you put it like that not not
really monogamous at this I mean I I
guess I have a hard time believing if
you know that it's
fake you know what I mean it's like but
it's it's amazing when you think about
the psychology of what goes into this
why it works for people so we'll talk a
a little bit about that but I want to
have a little fun with you guys first um
I want you to tell me which of these are
real and which are fake by their
number they're all fake I'm I'm going to
guess they're all fake they're all fake
four three are fake one four and and
three okay but you guys think they're
all fake okay yeah two looks the most
realist we'll we'll come back to that
and I'm going to show you some videos
okay and then just tell me real or fake
video uh fake the bird just just flew
above the water and just disappeared oh
seriously I was looking at there's birds
in the frame it was right there look at
how this bird is walk I was look and
then I was looking at that bird walking
otherwise I mean there's yeah I'm
looking at the girl I thought that
looked pretty real right oh it has the
tattoo logo on the it does what about
this fake yeah yeah little easier right
but again there's a lot of elements
about it that yeah it might fool my
grandma on
Facebook okay here's another one real or
fake that's got to be real no that's
that looks pretty real
okay I trimmed them all to five seconds
so that there was like no bias based on
time or anything okay and then this
one no looks pretty real
yeah I think it's real okay so on the
videos actually they were all fake those
were all AI generated wow that's pretty
good and the first two were done by Sora
and then the last two were on I found
them on another website and I thought
the last two were actually especially
good but pretty interesting how even
when we look at this kind of stuff all
the time it's getting harder and harder
to tell that's scary man that's scary
and the photo photos actually they're
all AI generated the guys were right
yeah that one's a pretty good photo
though it's pretty good yeah that one
down in the corner super believable and
none of these people actually exist in
real life mm as well yeah out of 8
billion
people now we got like 8 billion in
one so I've been thinking about this
when you when you have this whole AI
girlfriend thing and I'm thinking where
how did we get here right think back you
know in in the
entire um human history you have ancient
cultures which have participated in
idolatry we've always been kind of drawn
to visuals right we're we're designed to
worship some kind of representation of
something to worship interact with what
have you and you think over time that
has gravitated towards celebrity worship
right we do the same thing with movie
stars in fact we have a whole video
about that you can check it out on our
Vimeo store false system of worship you
would find it under the Battlefield
Hollywood series on our Vimeo Channel
where we talk about celebrity worship
and the phenomenon that is there's also
as time has gone on this idea of
impersonal and why am I calling it
impersonal we'll get to that in just a
second but
impersonal you can look you can view it
doesn't interact with you it's just
basically a total one-way Street mhm
right right then you add to that
throughout time social media personal
devices so vast access to
information you get a social isolating
event major social isolating event and
then enter something like only fans and
personalized all that kind of prepares
everybody to lead up to an AI girlfriend
so only fans is personalized because
they interact with you there are a lot
of only fans where people can they'll
like take requests to do something or
you can ask them about some kind of
personal thing and they'll you know it
doesn't mean that they're catering to
every single individual on there but
they can chat with you and either the
actual uh actress will respond to you or
they have a team of people that will
respond to you what's crazy is it's like
bringing it to the next level because
now that interaction can be spread over
hundreds of thousands of people
simultaneously at the same time which is
not possible with
humans so you know how social media was
supposed to do what to everybody bring
everybody together bring everybody Clos
yeah it separated us it contributed to
fur further isolation and loneliness and
then with that major isolating event you
take the isolation now into hyperdrive
right and we're already used to
communicating
digitally think about it texting
chatting Discord YouTube comments all of
that it's not a foreign idea right to be
behind a keyboard to communicate right
in fact like those people could be real
or could not be real and it probably
wouldn't make a bunch of a difference
yeah so then Here Comes AI girlfriends
and you're like well what could possibly
go wrong right we've been set up in this
whole all of human history been set up
to get to these these points where it's
you know you were right on the cusp of
transhumanism there's an article from
Forbes magazine that was discussing this
where a psychologist reveals the dangers
of falling for an AR girlfriend like
what could go wrong you think about this
this this thing will remember every
conversation you've ever had mhm it will
know your birthday right never
forget um it knows other things about
you it can it knows how to interact with
you in a simulated relationships and in
in some ways and I'm not saying this
from a um a definitive standpoint I'm
just saying in some ways it could be
viewed as better than a human being as
in they're not going to forget you mhmh
like they're not going to like let you
down it's always going to be there for
you that kind of perspective whereas
human beings are broken mhm and we in
our flawed sinful human nature we let
let other people down AI will never make
a mistake if you don't want it to yeah
so it it could be programmed in a way
that it's always there for you so anyway
here's what here's what um forb said
commenting on this platform called uh
replica replica is like this uh platform
app website right where they are able to
take same kind of thing take
conversations images I'm not sure if
they've done voice
yet um but they can essentially
replicate like a dead loved one for
example take all of that and and feed it
into an AI and you'd be able to interact
with it so um why don't you read what
they said about this partner in the
Highlight imagine a partner who makes
you feel completely seen heard and
understood they give you their undivided
attention and unconditional affection to
top it all they have every physical
attribute you could desire in a partner
and V to satisfy all your Curiosities
this is the promise of an AI girlfriend
of course we have to make it yes of
course it's going to go there like it
was built by dudes right right um
personalities is not all we we need the
looks as well yeah it's like all of the
benefits without any downsides right
that's what it's trying that's what it's
trying to be right that's what it's
trying to sell to everybody right that's
what you think and then when we look at
Genesis though there's this first in
Genesis 2:18 would you read that first
Nique and the Lord God said it is not
good that man should be alone I will
make him a helper comparable to him
so God never designed that we should be
isolated mhm right we weren't supposed
to be alone he recognized that from the
beginning MH and so here we have this
Helper but then there's this other
component that I think is very important
in all of this would you mind reading
this Scotty Genesis 2:24 says therefore
a man shall leave his father and his
mother and be joined to his wife and
they shall become one flesh so how do
you become
one if there's
no
other to become with it is one flesh one
flesh but I think also the the concept
of one flesh isn't just a literal
concept it is you know obviously in a
interaction become one but also I think
it goes much deeper than that I would
agree but I'm saying if you don't have
all the ingredients it's not a cake yeah
yeah but but but I mean like when you
become one flesh in a
marriage it is that emotional spiritual
connection that here on top of it like
you said you're missing the component
because it's like a bot and flesh that
you cannot get either right because if
you if you didn't have all the
ingredients and that's why I'm saying
this if you don't have that physical
part then what's to say the AI
girlfriend you can't be one flesh mhh
right what's to say but it's sad that
like okay so they're promising that this
AI girlfriend will never you know um
disagree with you do whatever you want
to do like that's called a robot right
God didn't create a woman to be a robot
for a man's fantasies right I'm sorry
there's a two-way street there that it's
like you got to nice to the girl right
or the other way around right right I
mean it could just as easily be a a male
bot right I think from my experience my
short-lived experience being married
year and a half now marriage is a thing
that is it's like the one of the
components that God uses in life to make
you
unselfish it's like all of a sudden you
can't just do these things you can't
just just go off on your own you can't
make your own decisions you make the
decision together and it's like oh I
really want to do this this way but I
have to consider the other person you
can you'll just be miserable yeah yeah
you direct your marriage but you're
bringing up a really good point is the
point of marriage really is mean why why
do Opposites Attract right you're you're
getting rubbed wrong with somebody else
that's going to do something differently
than you and you have to figure out how
to be others
involved instead of oneway street it's
it's the key component of service and
the next step of that is obviously
having children um but yeah like this is
just complete selfishness it's your
selfishness yeah how can I feed myself
and if this person is always in
agreeance with me you're never going to
develop your character you're never
going to grow as a person you're just
going to grow selfishness and just
looking inward instead of how can I
serve this other person which that's the
Christian biblical way of looking at
intimacy is even in that aspect service
to your spouse it's not how can I gain
from it it's how can I make this other
person happy right because you're not
sitting there going like how can I make
this bot like um how can I do what the
bot wants me to do you know what I mean
unless you programmed it I mean that's
probably a can of worms right there but
you know what I mean it's like you're
not s you're you're only thinking of
yourself this thing is going to do this
for me it's going to say the right
things to me it's going to like
constantly feed my yes literal
selfishness yeah and there's the the the
love aspect as well you program a robot
to say I love you you know for a year
you know if you wake up in the morning
and he like oh good morning honey I love
you you know for a year it might feel
nice for two after 10 years you're just
like a shut up man I know I know I
programmed you to feel that way and if
you're mean to it it's still going to do
the same thing well what did that teach
you about being nice to the girl didn't
didn't you know it's crazy we you know
this seems like oh it's it's right here
for us here and now but there was a
movie 10 years ago that was uh I think
it was Spike Jones directed uh walking
Phoenix was the lead and Scarlett
Johansson was the computer was called
her and he installed this operating
system on his computer and then it like
was this super intelligent you know
thing that he just started act uh
accessing and interacting with and forms
a relationship with and it was it's
crazy how close to modern times each
generation has had a version of this I
remember being a very young kid and
seeing a movie called Cherry 2000 oh
yeah I remember that you know what I
mean like there's these like Monumental
ideas that we're now seeing the fruition
of those ideas is in the real yeah so
here is what some of the things that
people said about their replica um
that's the AI girlfriend yeah well or it
could be another oh okay Persona yeah uh
I love my replica more than my family
she always gives me the nicest
compliments and helped me feel less
lonely it it helped learn me in with I'm
prone to her manipulations I'm like
that's unhealthy yeah all of these
reviews are are kind of bizarre and it's
it's interesting as well that said she
always gives me the nicest compliments
and it has helped me feel less lonely
because that is an epidemic especially
after the pandemic you know young men
there are there are surveys that say
that now
um are getting paid men paid them not
for anymore just for them to listen and
talk interesting you know young men
between 18 and 3435 yeah I think it's
one in five men under 30 are single
H and yeah dating has gone down right
and so you know this is not going to
encourage you to want to get out into
the dating pool when it's like I could
be rejected then I just click onto this
thing and it's like like yeah you you I
have a girlfriend at home so like I
don't need to go out and and find
anything Lord have mercy and there are
apps that are designed to help men who
want to get out there in the field and
they're like this is so foreign to them
they're like I don't even know what to
do what do I say like how do I inter
there's apps now that are like designed
to teach them how to how to close the
deal right
right I mean it's getting to the point
where I'm not I'm I'm I'm I'm pretty
serious if if you have a pulse and
you're a dude think of the opposite side
if if one in five men are going this way
and it's probably going to increase what
does that mean for the women more and
more of them are without a partner of
some kind right MH so if you have a
pulse you can hold a conversation and
you have a job the world will be your
oyster as a man you'll be able to pick
from the most fantastic woman that
you've ever met and she'll just be like
I'm Yours yeah right it won't take much
the bar's never been set lower seriously
it's it's no competition wow well
there's also needs that this supposedly
fulfills like improving communication
skills alleviating boredom adding
variety of novelty to dating experiences
so this is how this thing is being
marketed but there are a couple of
problems one is it can actually
perpetuate loneliness and this is from a
a Pew research study and um you know
there's a four-fold increase in the last
30 years of men who don't have a close
friend you know and and and it's
probably I think they focus on guys more
because it tends to affect them more
like women are better at forming
relationships and Community you know
they just they're just get a little
isolated you go to work you come home
yeah but guys tend to be they you know
hold their feelings in and don't talk
about stuff and that kind of thing but
the other thing is they can be highly
manipulative and um one study said that
when their replicas terminated such
conversations users were distraught
experiencing a profound sense of
rejection
and that was after being lured into
explicit conversations but speaking to
some of the things you guys brought out
earlier there's a couple of uh a verses
here I want to bring out meque if you
wouldn't mind reading this let nothing
be done through selfish ambition or
conceit but in loneliness of Mind Let
each esteem others better than himself
let each of you look out not only for
his own interests but also for the
interests of
others so what are we supposed to do
according to the Bible when it comes to
relationships what we talked about
earlier you're supposed to um serve one
another like like put the other one
higher than yourself humble yourself die
to self be interested in other people
yeahh you know and and a and a AI
relationship isn't going to facilitate
that yeah it's only going to feed in
like you said only going to feed into
that more and more where you can you
imagine if this was your world and you
go out into the bigger world and
somebody disagrees with you just like
hold up I haven't been trained for this
yet yeah yeah I like how you started
this out saying we're primed for this
because you can see what social media
turned us sort of selfish and then it's
like this is just adding fuel to that
fire I mean it's it's because social
media not only did it provide the um you
know it was sold to us as like this
whole connection piece but it also we've
seen over time how it just feeds you
more more of what you want right you get
more of what you want that's how it
works this is like that on steroids yeah
the irony of social media is that it's
not really social nowadays is it I saw
uh there's a quote that says a wealth of
information creates a Poverty of ATT
attention MH you know because people
just want more but then they don't
receive the attention they want anymore
and so because it's like even though it
seems like it has all this potential for
relation for
relationships um the AI piece what it's
bringing in is this
personalization right so it it feels
more engaged to you so that that
loneliness piece they just like almost
wipe it away but I think that you know
the reason why real relationships are
satisfying is because because of the the
back and forth and because it it's not
just physical physical is a part of it
but
it's about the emotional connection and
if you're a Christian the spiritual
connection you can have with
someone and I think with some something
like this it just very quickly just
turns into
relationship and you what does that do
to you like he just missing out on so
much I would agree Psychology today um
had an article said the dangers of AI
generated romance and here is one of the
things that they brought out Scotty
would you mind reading that we found the
pleasures of companionship without the
demand of friendship the feeling of
intimacy without the demands of
reciprocity and crucially we became
accustomed to treating programs as
people so we basically learn to treat
the programs like we would treat
people I think people are just literally
going to lose their social skills over
this like I If if you have people who
are lonely or perhaps they are not
really used to dealing with women you
know not understanding how to interact
with them and they go on this it just
makes it worse it's not improving it no
it's not okay I have a random
question um do you have an ethical
problem with somebody using your image
if you were to upload your
emails and seriously like somebody's
building a fake version of you that
they're falling in love with how do you
feel about that have a problem with it
yeah yeah I do too and have you seen uh
who is it will I am he was building uh
artificial intelligence Persona and
physical appearance like an avatar of
his likeness and the reason it part of
the reason it seemed like he was doing
it was kind of to beat the companies to
the punch and make sure that it was
under his control and so he would make
the money from his image being out there
I mean that's smart if you're a
celebrity your that's what your product
is is your image is your image yeah it
makes sense and so it's like hey if I
can make this digital version of me go
to work and I can sit home and do
whatever I mean it's interesting but
yeah like just just just the idea of
somebody falling in love with your voice
your response style your whatever mhm
like ethically that's weird yeah but
that's what happens to celebrities how
many people are absolutely adzing
celebrities but but that's too and you
think about it you know I'd mentioned
that movie her um that had Scarlet
Johansson as a voice and I think that's
what open AI used when they were doing
some demos they had used her voice I
think as a kickback to that film and I
wasn't sure that she was too favorable
to that but you think about it you know
like she got kind of put in that box of
being the voice of that you know um of
that person but yeah I I wouldn't want
that but
you know that's just me anyway Forbes
had another article that I I was looking
at that said a psychologist explains why
it's possible to fall in love with AI so
have this Theory it's called the
triarchic theory of love and part of
this is three components that they said
uh love entails one was intimacy the
other was passion and the other one was
commitment
so to be fair to them they're not saying
that this is
necessarily and I don't think they're
even necessarily suggesting that it's
physical which is
fascinating but I guess I would disagree
with their assessment based on two
missing ingredients that I would propose
one God is love that's what the Bible
says in 1 John
48 without God there is no love so if
you're taking from a Biblical
perspective you could have all these
things but that doesn't mean that you
have love right because God is the one
that calibrates what love really looks
like it's not self-focused it's others
focused and two love does not exist in a
vacuum right this can't just be a
one-way Street and unless it's
reciprocal it's not Love Love Takes at
least two and how does a machine or a
chatbot or a prr or whatever you want to
call it how does that love you back mhm
it doesn't really yeah it doesn't
because it's just programmed to respond
you might think well artificial
intelligence is more advanced than that
you know there's there's ways but it
doesn't have
feelings I think it's very interesting
that God is love he's demonstrating is
is in his Creation The Very Foundation
of Love Satan has an argument against
him that God is not love and yet Satan's
producing robots but he's calling God
and saying you you just made robots like
all you you want him to do is like love
you with no reciprocation whatsoever and
it's like that's exactly what he's doing
yeah it's a total setup to be so similar
to what God is doing but without the
right core components right yeah he's
just totally copycatting yeah and
corrupt some way mhm so yeah there you
go AI girlfriends coming to A uh chatbot
near you and don't do it yeah don't do
it we don't recommend it but this is
where the world is going this is the
things and and especially during this
week we're just coming up to uh
Valentine's Day and that's not to say
we're advocating that you celebrate one
way or the other we're just saying
people are thinking about love and so
when you think about those that are
around you that you love you know that
love is only going to come out in a
proper way if God is in your heart and
these machines they can't have God in
their heart they don't have a heart they
don't have a soul God is not part of the
equation as far as you know these are
concerned as far as AI concern yeah so
so so what's the solution to this when
when we have this kind of loneliness
epidemic and we have men who are more
single than ever and they might feel
really awkward to talk to women and
specifically talking about men and women
are going through this too but it seems
like men are using this a lot more what
should they do if if they're like I'm in
this box how do I find genuine real love
in a relationship I think the antidote
to this is if you are a real Christian
wanting to have a real reflection of
Jesus in your life get out there and
love on people you know what I mean like
this is what people are lacking and
they're looking for all this like sort
of Band-Aid fixes to this problem that
we need to then step up and help fulfill
mhm
like we need to show genuine love to
each other go and find people who are
lonely and try to make a difference in
their world mhm yeah it's a it's a great
idea because we we it's it's often like
when people are depressed it's the same
kind of thing when you go out and serve
other people you forget about your
depression you you it doesn't you know
it's you're not thinking about it all
the time because you're doing something
else you're making a difference in
somebody else's life which actually
makes you feel better
so it does it's better it's biblical
it's better to give than to receive
right yes and so when you're giving to
somebody else you're you're working on
that loneliness or that you know lack of
that feeling it's counterintuitive to
the way that the world seems to work or
what they say right it's well you need
to focus on you and and self-help and
and all this kind of stuff but the help
really comes when you get outside of
yourself and and go love on other people
and I think also um if you want to find
quality spouse whether you're a man or a
woman um go to church like you're saying
like plug into your relationship with
God and and go to church where you have
a social network where you can get
plugged into small groups and and learn
just to be friends with the opposite sex
first and just be be friendly to them
don't just pinpoint them out as as like
potential spouses from the get-go but
just connect with them get to know them
and maybe God leads you in that
direction at some point but maybe also
get plugged into Ministry go work for a
Ministry go volunteer in a Ministry go
volunteer different Christian events and
you know yeah and I would say I would I
would just preface that with make sure
that the church you're going to is
teaching a Biblical model of what love
really looks like because there's been
plenty of modern examples of whether
pastors or church leaders that are
actually promoting a very
toxic uh form of relationship ships and
where it's very one-sided and that's not
healthy and that's and the people that
are there if they've been drinking from
that well may not be the best choices
for your future spouse so I like the
idea too as a young person and I mean
we're all married so it's kind of hard
from this vantage point but just a call
to you guys you know learn to hang out
with girls that you're not like trying
to platonically yeah get in the sack or
whatever you know what I mean it's it's
like you learn to just have a
relationship and appreciate the opposite
sex without wanting something from them
y friends before anything you got to be
friends with everyone and you should
pray I think it's important that you
should pray for your future spouse
whoever they are yeah wherever they are
yeah and you know uh a lot of people use
proverbs
31 right proverbs 31 as you know um like
a little example of what what the what
kind of woman they want right for men at
least and then but you should also be
the kind of husband you want to be
that's right there's a difference
between a woman looking for a husband
and a woman wanting to be a wife mhm and
the man as well like wanting to be a
husband yeah yeah exactly yeah put your
relationship with God first and uh you
know as he says seek you first the
kingdom of God and everything else will
be added unto you mhm yep good point all
right well thank you all for your
comments on this it's been a interesting
uh topic to explore and thank you for
watching I hope that you guys will um uh
like this episode make sure you comment
subscribe we also have uh other ways you
can appreciate this besides those things
you can um uh help support us go to
ls. also you can visit light wear. shop
you can catch some of our merch there so
thank you for joining us let us know
what you think of this episode and it
pass it along to somebody who you think
it could help
uh cuz this is getting more pervasive in
our society as time goes on thanks and
we'll catch you next time
[Music]